more questions and answers regarding a
deadly fire in north las vegas
that fire took the life of a
four-year-old child a four-year-old boy
the fire happening last night in webster
circle near cheyenne and civic center
joe mohler joining us there live and joe
there is some concern that
no adults were there in that home with
the four and eight-year-old when the
fire broke out
that's right neighbors tell us they did
not see any adults here when this fire
did break out a landlord who just
stopped by a short time ago told us
that the people who were living here the
woman was actually running an errand at
the grocery store and she says she was
gone for about 20 minutes now this is
the home where this all happened
now here's the latest of what we know
neighbors could hear screaming when the
fire broke out after six
tuesday evening the people next door ran
outside and called 9-1-1
they noticed the eight-year-old girl
outside the home yelling and tried to
help the four-year-old boy who was
still inside adrian castillo who lives a
few doors down
he says the family is fairly new to the
neighborhood
they're very long it was a rental and to
tell you the truth i don't know which
ones were the parents and which ones
weren't
the children that were left alone
it's unbelievable just
couldn't believe they would do that
the boy who has not been identified yet
was taken to umc where he was pronounced
dead the eight-year-old girl is said to
be doing okay now back on here live
we have reached out to north las vegas
fire to ask if these children were
indeed left alone as well
as the cause so we are waiting to get an
update from the north las vegas police
police department and the fire
department as this investigation does
continue
reporting live in north las vegas this
evening joe mohler 8 news now